[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 3 décembre bienvenue dans
le journal préparé par la rédaction de
tv 60,18 voici les titres de cette
édition la disparition de valéry giscard
d'estaing à 94 ans l'ancien président de
la république est décédé hier des suites
du colis de 19 majorité à 18 ans
dépénalisation de l'avortement des
réformes progressistes ont été adoptées
lors de son unique septennat entre 1974
et 1981 valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
une vie aussi dédié à l'europe il est
venu en 2005 à louveciennes défendre le
projet de constitution
initiateur également d'un premier sommet
mondial futur g7 à rambouillet en 1975
retour sur ses liens avec les yvelines
et réactions à suivre des principales
figures politiques du département
et puis dans le reste de l'actualité une
journée nationale consacrée au cinéma
indépendant l'objectif défendre les
salles de proximité avec cette année le
contexte particulier de la crise
sanitaire reportage aux clayes sous bois
et elancourt et invités gauthier barra
directeur de la société versaillaise km5
production en fin de journal également
présentation et découverte du cèdre bleu
de montesson il est en course pour
devenir l'arbre de l'année
[Musique]
mais à valéry giscard d'estaing s'est
donc éteint hier à l'âge de 94 ans des
suites du corona virus admis à l'hôpital
georges pompidou en septembre il avait
été de nouveau hospitalisé à la mi
novembre à tours
20e président de l'histoire de l'après
de l'histoire de la république française
il est lors de son élection le 27 mai
1974 le plus jeune président de la vème
république à 48 ans de centre-droit
d'inspiration et démocrate chrétienne
valéry giscard d'estaing est le premier
président non gaullistes sont uniques
septennat jusqu'en 1980 voient
l'aboutissement de réformes
progressistes à l'aboutissement de
l'aboutissement de ces réformes
l'abaissement notamment de la majorité à
18 ans dépénalisation de l'avortement
elles libéralisation de l'information
encore est divorce par consentement
mutuel
battus en 1981 par françois mitterrand
son adversaire déjà sept ans plus tôt il
dédiera le reste de sa vie aux lettres
entre ans à l'académie française en 2003
mais aussi à l'europe nous en
reparlerons tout à l'heure chantre
également valéry giscard d'estaing des
relations internationales il est à
l'origine d'une première mondiale qui
s'est déroulé à rambouillet les 15 16 et
17 novembre 1975 et les chefs d'état et
du gouvernement des six pays acp les
plus puissants se rassemblent à la
france le royaume-uni les etats-unis la
république fédérale d'allemagne
l'italie et le japon un rassemblement à
l'initiative du président français
le choix du lieu se porte sur le château
de rambouillet le domaine accueille les
chasses présidentielles depuis 100 ans
cette première réunion est consacrée aux
problèmes économiques et monétaires ce
groupe sera nommé le g6 qui deviendra
ensuite le g7 qui existe encore
aujourd'hui et valéry giscard d'estaing
viendra d'ailleurs encore à rambouillet
lee réunira plusieurs fois des conseils
des ministres notamment en avril 1975
est également en 1978 on continue de
parler de cette disparition de valéry
giscard d'estaing avec patrice carmouze
bonsoir directeur de l'information atv
78 talent giscard d'estaing est l'un des
présidents elle est plus
les mets de cette 5ème république et
vous trouvez ce jugement assez injuste
ne croient guère et 5 % des français
qu'il procéderait comme un bon président
il trouvé sa bible injuste oui juste
pour plusieurs raisons premier réseau
d'abord c'est un européen convaincu il
est né en 26 et avant la guerre donc
c'était le dernier président vivant qui
avait connu la guerre et comme tous ceux
qui ont connu la guerre et il
considérait que la construction
européenne comme un gage de paix et il
ya eu d'abord cet axe franco allemand
avec son ami le chancelier helmut
schmidt et qui est caf fondé le repas
cet axe franco-allemand di noto dit
qu'il est très important dans la
construction de l'europe c'est à lui
qu'on doit aussi l'élection du parlement
européen au suffrage universel
il a fait en sorte que ce soit simone
veil qui soit la première présidente du
parlement européen c'est à lui aussi
qu'on doit le système monétaire européen
et même les prémices de ce que sera leur
où il avait d'ailleurs trouvé un nom
presque france et elle est qu un ils
veulent et ça s'appelle les véhicules
l'unité communes aux européennes
donc c'est donc c'est il a fait beaucoup
pour pour l'europe même si pour des
raisons d'ailleurs de politique est
interdite ou rester un franco européen
quinquin fédéraliste et c'est lui qui a
aussi écrit le projet de constitution
open dans les années 2000 qui sera
retoqué d'ailleurs pas le référendum de
on parlera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
dans ce journal c'est aussi un
réformateur valéry giscard d'estaing
oui incontestablement lives et j'ai la
majorité à 18 ans le divorce par
consentement mutuel
au fond ils avaient été marqués par mai
68 et il ya deux possibilités qu'on vous
avait été marquée comme mai 68 il ya
chirac chirac qui s'était dit si on
bouge la société française
elle va éclater dont il est urgent de ne
rien faire et giscard qui considèrent au
contraire qu'il valait mieux réformer la
société pour ne pas pour ne pas se
retrouver face à des événements comme
mai 68 et il l'a fait souvent pensant
contre son camp en passant presque même
contre lui-même votre ses convictions
religieuses ni viseur la tribu beaucoup
à simone weill et c'est vrai qu'elle
était extrêmement courageuse mais enfin
c'est lui qui était qui était quand même
derrière 7,7 cette réforme
j'ajoute aussi
seul était conseillé par jean-jacques
servan-schreiber qui coïncide avec la
politique devait protéger les individus
contre les désastres la guerre
économique les difficultés économiques
et c'est à lui qu'on doit par exemple
l'indemnisation 90% du chômage des gens
qui étaient au chômage ce qui était
quand même très courageux tu veux qu'il
reste est aujourd'hui de lui sa
personnalité peut-être alors c'est
peut-être là que le bât blesse un peu
yves des côtes est formidable la
campagne de 74 était très moderne de
dire si ç'avait été aujourd'hui de
réutiliser les réseaux sociaux il n'y
avait pas comme comme les autres une
grande machine politique derrière lui
donc il fallait qu'il aille directement
face à face au public
il a très bien fait mais c'est vrai que
le pouvoir un peu changé c'est cédés
hors du pouvoir qu est ce que vous les
connaissez la phrase de de gaulle qui
disait que pour le de giscard c'est le
peuple
alors c'est vrai que l'état c'est
maladroit quand il recevait les les
éboueurs à l'elysée quand il a des lits
dîner chez des gens tout ça était il ya
un côté un peu un peu ridicule quand
même il a pas su vraiment s'y prendre
quoi quoi avec le avec le peuple et du
coup sa personnalité sa politique sont
un peu réduits à la fin du septennat
il s'est un peu figé faut ajouter à cela
un sens de la symbolique qui était pas
toujours des des plus heureux vous
souvenez tous au revoir à la fin de
certains droits 80 étaient les leurs il
y avait pas mal repris sans compter que
ben en 80 aussi il a été il était
emporté par le désir d'alternance ça
faisait plus de vingt ans que la droite
était au pouvoir et ce sont peut-être
ces éléments qui expliquent le jugement
des français et il est possible qu'avec
sa disparition pas ce jugement se
changent un peu il soit un peu plus
juste vis-à-vis de son action politique
merci patrice patrice carmouze directeur
de l'information atv 78 alors les
hommages pleuvent depuis l'annoncé hier
du décès de valéry giscard d'estaing à
regarder d'abord ces images
à l'assemblée nationale hier soir une
minute de silence a été observée par les
députés on précise d'ailleurs que
valérie
giscard d'estaing était également
députés à six reprises avant et après
son mandat de président de la république
un moment de recueillement également du
côté du sénat ce matin vous l'avez vue
sur ces images le président de la
chambre haute sénateur des yvelines et
ex maire de rambouillet gérard larcher
s'est lui même exprimé ce matin chez nos
confrères de france inter
il s'agit il salue une intelligence
fulgurante et son rôle également dans la
modernisation des rapports de la société
écoutait valéry giscard d'estaing a aidé
à changer quelque part la gouvernance de
ce pays
moi je le voyais à peu près chaque année
c'était une intelligence fulgurante tout
le monde le sait et je me souviens
encore de notre dernière rencontre nous
avions évoquée pourquoi il réforme
constitutionnelle ne pouvait pas être
fait dans la pulsion
parmi les autres réactions valérie
pécresse s'est exprimée sur twitter la
présidente de la région ile de france
souligne un homme qui croyant la france
et en europe qui aimait la jeunesse qui
défendit le droit des femmes
il était cultivé brillant en racine en
auvergne et passionné de politique
adieu monsieur le président nous dit
l'ancien député des yvelines actuelle
conseillère municipale de vélizy
villacoublay droit de vote à 18 ans il
et j'ai tgv musée d'orsay alors non ça
c'est la réaction pardon de pierre
bédier qui nous est proposée le
président les républicains du
département des yvelines qui salue
notamment un homme de culture un homme
qui a oeuvré pour la réforme en france
droit de vote à 18 ans ivg tgv musée
d'orsay ça c'est la réaction que nous
vous proposons à présent indépendance
nucléaire également saisine du conseil
constitutionnel divorce par consentement
mutuel est libéralisation de
l'audiovisuel conseil européen élection
au suffrage universel des membres du
parlement européen et tout cela en sept
ans ça c'est le bilan dressé par
philippe benassaya député de la 11e
circonscription à propos de la
disparition est de valéry giscard
d'estaing passionné d'histoire le député
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
ex-maire de bois d'arcy a écrit sur les
années de présidence de giscard
d'estaing entre 1974 et 1981 un
président dont on se souvient finalement
peu dans l'histoire est assez
injustement patrice carmouze en parler
tout à l'heure regardez ce qu'ils
disaient c'était dans l'émission café
politique est diffusé en 2016 sur tv 78
ans n'a été coincé entre le gaullisme
précédent et le socialisme et donc on a
fait de valéry giscard d'estaing une
parenthèse une parenthèse politique
alors que c'était pas une parenthèse je
pense que moi la première grande
alternance sous la 5ème république c'est
valérie jusqu'à mais ça et c'est pas
françois mitterrand c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing parce qu'ils abhorraient
imposer un nouveau style une nouvelle
politique française il a fait monter une
nouvelle génération
et puis quand vous avez égrainé tous les
projets tous les projets toutes les
réformes de valérie stroh dessin c'est
un truc incroyable je suis persuadé que
la postérité
on vendra justice à ce septennat
peut-être pas un homme parce qu'on a
tous nos failles et tout ce défaut mais
la postérité rendre à mon avis hommage à
7 à cette base il est pas la place
qu'ils méritent aujourd'hui est d'abord
il a été étrillé par les médias
qui n'est qu'une caricature tend
aujourd'hui à les regarder ça a été un
grand septennat très honnêtement alors
bienveillant oui pourquoi pas mais
critique aussi parce qu'il ya eu aussi
des erreurs comme dans tout septennat il
ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs et beaucoup de
maladresses et beaucoup dé beaucoup de
de ce no scandale fr les diamants et un
pseudo scandale qui n'a jamais existé
par exemple quelques dernières réactions
politiques à vous proposer celle d'une
personnalité yvelinoise politiques
alliées à valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
nicolas abou maire de montigny le
bretonneux de 1977 à 2004 il a été aussi
est député de la 8e circonscription des
yvelines en 1978 engagé dans le parti
giscardien de l'udf union pour la
démocratie française il se souvient
d'avoir reçu le soutien du président de
la république lors de l'élection
législative les propos sont accueillis
par nicolas landry guide est porté de 76
me suis engagé en politique pour aider à
cette transformation qui l'a gardé
j'essaie la campagne de 74 et c'était un
réel bonheur de voir son succès et puis
j'ai été candidat en 78 et je n'oublie
pas que le président giscard d'estaing a
tenu à m'appeler le soir les premiers
tours pour me dire combien l'espérait ma
victoire au second tour
donc sur cette huitième circonscription
des yvelines rambouillet et trappes
valéry giscard d'estaing est également
de et de également venu pardon à de
nombreuses reprises dans la commune de
saint germain en laye le 6 mai 1981 il
avait notamment visité la maison de la
légion d'honneur ce jour là le président
s'était ensuite rendu à l'hôtel de ville
pour un discours avant de se rendre au
lycée international de saint germain en
laye un établissement ont fréquenté à ce
moment là par arnaud péricard à l'actuel
maire de la commune avait 9 ans à cette
époque elle était élève en 1ère dans
l'établissement il se souvient de cet
instant interrogé par michael et demi
d'euros très bien dépendre la grande
allée du lycée international
il faut bien également se remémorer que
valéry giscard d'estaing était un
européen convaincu et que ce lycée qui à
l'époque voilà commencé à se développer
avec toute réflexion internationale
c'était une expérimentation pédagogique
il intéressé au plus haut point il était
venu effectivement non seulement rendre
hommage à ces enseignements mais aussi
s'informer sur cette possibilité de
dispenser des enseignements en
différentes langues
en france le 12 mai 2005 valéry giscard
d'estaing étaient venus également du
côté de luz yens pour défendre le projet
de constitution européenne le référendum
sur le traité pour l'établir allait
avoir lieu dans quelques jours plus tard
en france car toute sa vie on l'a dit
dans ce journal il était un européen
convaincu avec le chancelier allemand
helmut schmidt il participe à la
création du comité pour l'union
monétaire de l'europe en 1986 est député
européen après sa présidence entre 1989
et 1993 président de la convention
européenne dont est issu cette
convention cette constitution européenne
la première dans l'histoire de l'europe
écouter ce qu'il disait à l'époque à
notre micro
depuis 15 ans il n'y a pas eu en france
le grand débat sur l'europe le dernier
remonte à maastricht et de plus les
français non plus bien phû compris quel
était le rôle de l'europe conscient
fonctionner et un des fiat un
désenchantement sur l'europe et donc ses
banques une discussion cette diffusion
est utile parce que j'ai chaude et moi
je ne souhaite pas que les français
votent sur comprendre le texte de clic
on parle de tests et quand c'est yves
bot de préférence actuellement oui et
donc je pense que ce débat est tout à
fait utile il faut pas lui donner un
caractère polémique causée par un vote à
l'intérieur de la france un vote en
europe sur l'europe et le 29 mai 2005
les français à 54 67% voteront contre ce
traité pour établir une constitution
européenne
échec de ce combat donc mené par valéry
giscard d'estaing mais il restera comme
l'un des pères fondateurs de l'union
européenne comme le précise et des gens
en 2018 le directeur de la maison jean
monnet qui est installé à bazoches sur
guyonne avant même d'être
élu président de la république valéry
giscard d'estaing avait une vision
engagé européenne il
été très tôt
dire impressionné par le projet
première construction européenne et qui
l'avait soutenu il avait défendu le
traité de rome même au sein de son
propre parti à l'époque
et puis bien écouter quand il a été élu
plutôt président de la république en
c'est une époque charnière importante
pour l'europe puisque c'est l'époque on
a commencé à s'intéresser à la fin un
système monétaire européen qui devait
préfigurer le la monnaie unique nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est une époque où
on a aussi commencé à parler de certains
élargissement de l'europe
et puis on était dans une époque encore
de guerre froide
et valéry giscard d'estaing a tout de
suite compris aussi l'importance de
continuer à faire travailler le couple
franco allemand comme moteur de la
construction européenne par la suite
quand le président giscard d'estaing
n'était plus président il a continué à
oeuvrer pour la construction européenne
la convention s'achève aujourd'hui
j'aurais lutins et de proposer la
première constitution pour l'europe
malheureusement n'a pas vu le jour en
totalité puisque vous le savez en 2005
un référendum d'abord en france puis en
europe et pas à rejeter un ce traité on
a vu d'abord que l'opinion un peu se
détachait du projet européen et elle
s'en détachaient parce qu'elle voyait
plus l'objectif est la vue l'objectif au
début parce que c'est à la paire devrait
bien tu peu à peu le système est devenu
opaque c'était une bureaucratie ou
perçus comme grassi on ne voyait pas
très bien que tel est l'objectif que
c'était pour faire quoi
souvent on a reproché au traité
constitutionnel de pas avoir été
démocratique pourtant cette convention
représentait absolument toutes les
sensibilités tous les partis politiques
et la société civile
mais elle a peut-être pas bénéficié
d'autant de publicité keller
communication quel con aurait souhaité
c'est derrière ces dernières images à
vous montrer celle ci a d'abord qui date
de 2018 valéry giscard d'estaing était à
versailles pour le salon histoire de
lire homme de lettres également entré à
l'académie française il était venu
débattre devant l'auditoire de
l'université interâges et puis ce cliché
qui nous est partagé par le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines pris dans la cour
du château l'ancien chef d'état était
devenu après la tempête de 1999 le
président d'honneur de l'association des
amis de la sauvegarde du parc de
dampierre ce qui avait permis la
replantation d'un bosquet des chimères
voilà ce que l'on pouvait vous dire les
réactions aussi que nous avons proposées
dans cette édition au lendemain de la
disparition de valéry giscard d'estaing
l'ancien président de la république de
1974 à 1980 s'est éteint hier mercredi 2
décembre à l'âge de 94 ans a porté par
le coronavirus emmanuel macron doit
s'exprimer à ce propos ce soir ce jeudi
soir à 20 heures
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité tout autre
chose c'est la journée nationale du
cinéma indépendant après une année très
difficile les cinémas devrait pouvoir
rouvrir le 15 décembre si la situation
sanitaire le permet dans les salles de
proximité on se prépare donc déjà au
retour du public dans le respect strict
des mesures sanitaires reportage aux
clayes-sous-bois et à elancourt avec
astrid bergère et patrick jacques de
dixmude à l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois on est prêt à
accueillir de nouveau le public dans les
deux salles que compte le cinéma cette
réouverture est très attendu après une
année difficile alors 2020 ça a
forcément été une année compliquée où on
a
on a donc comme à peu près toutes les
salles de france perdu 50 à 55% de notre
de notre fréquentation après la
réouverture prévue le 15 décembre le
public pourra compter sur la diffusion
de films pour tous les publics comme a
dû les courbes albert dupontel adn de
maïwenn ou encore polly de nicolas
vanier et pour sa séance le protocole
sanitaire sera scrupuleusement respectée
il ya évidemment du gel hydroalcoolique
disponible partout les masque est
obligatoire dans les salles pour toutes
les personnes à partir de 11 ans ça
c'est des choses qui sont maintenus nous
à l'espace noir est on a mis en place
également un sens de circulation au ciné
cette d'elancourt mêmes mesures
sanitaires
ici aussi on tient particulièrement à
mettre en avant le cinéma français
on va soutenir les films qui se sont
arrêtées de façon brutale notamment des
films français distribué par des
distributeurs français qu'on salue dans
toutes les salles de france parce que
heureusement qu'on a eu le cinéma
français et des distributeurs qui ont
comme snd comme vous mon cher ami de
diaphana fin et c'est sur une courage de
sortir des films
qui ont d'ailleurs été récompensé parce
que ça a bien fonctionné pour les
cinéphiles il reste moins de deux
semaines à patienter pour retrouver les
salles obscures
voilà pour le bilan de cette préparation
et de ce retour aux salles quel bilan
maintenant du côté des productions des
sociétés de production voit ça avec mon
invité gauthier barras bonsoir pense à
directoire et fondateur de kaïn cinq
produits production c'est une société de
production cinématographique
indépendante qui est basé à versailles
déjà une petite réaction sur cette
journée journées du cinéma indépendant
saint important de le défendre le cinéma
indépendant surtout avec cette année
particulière surtout en ce moment parce
que c'est vrai que le cinéma est très
touché surtout les salles de cinéma
entre les films qui sont décalées les
sorties maman dvd et où donc ça a été
une année particulière pour la
production cinématographique où les
tournages ont été quelque peu compliqué
avec les différents confinement alors
qu'on arrive à la fin de l'année quel
est le bilan que vous dressez vous à
l'échelle de votre société est ce que ça
a été une année difficile où est ce que
finalement le bilan est plutôt bon
malgré tout en fait le c'est plutôt bon
c'est plutôt bon donc c'est que la dir
parce qu'en fait on a eu on a été primée
énormément deux fois en fait sur les
finis on avait deux films en cours donc
le bon coin 1 réalisée par leur à
richard et le service réalisées par par
bruno henry les deux écrits par là même
le scénariste marine et le maillot est
en fait ces deux films l'un ont eu un
énorme et man 2
de sélection au festival et de prix le
service par exemple confronté je crois
plus de 28 prix avec une soixantaine de
sélections donc c'est plutôt bien dans
le monde entier parce que l'hélice
estivale en plus quand même se dérouler
même de manière online voilà beaucoup en
line
donc vraiment dans le monde entier donc
hollywood londres et tout est à côté on
a eu quand même une suppression de
tournage sur le 2ème confinement
parce qu'il ya eu des manques budgétaire
bien évidemment qui devait arriver
qu'ils ne sont pas arrivés à cause déjà
du premier confinement et du deuxième
des décalages de tournage on a pu quand
même avoir des stagiaires la prendre en
charge des stagiaires sur le 2ème
confinement mais ça a été plutôt
bénéfique année on va dire sur la
production plutôt mitigé mais en tout
cas sur le plan des récompenses il ya eu
à des récompenses pour vos productions
on rappelle que lors du premier
confinement les tournages étaient
strictement interdite ça a été de
nouveau autorisée pour ce deuxième
confinement vous êtes organisé comment
du coup est ce que vous avez fait
davantage d'écriture plutôt que du
tournage alors oui
j'ai terminé l'écriture mon deuxième
long métrage enfin qui est mon premier
véritable long j'en avais fait un dans
le passé qui s'appelait je les aime je
les aime tous tu sais et donc là je
viens de finir pas de pays sans paysans
qui est prévu pour d'ici deux ans le
tournage on prévoit du coup un peu plus
loin
mais voilà on a pu terminer les projets
monter les dossiers de production voilà
vraiment préparé beaucoup plus les
projets à venir
ceux ci on rappelle très brièvement les
étapes pour faire un film de comment ça
se passe concrètement alors donc on a
toute la post production
ensuite on va voir dont celle à 11
heures tous les dossiers de production
la recherche de financement les
producteurs associés et ensuite on part
sur le tournage puis la post production
qui va nous prendre encore un certain
temps pour arriver au final et à la
salle de cinéma trois étapes alors du
coup là les prochains mois de quoi
vont-ils être fait pour vous disiez il
ya des tournages qui ont été reportés ça
alors ça nous a permis également de nous
faire référencer enfin chez allociné
donc on a nos petits peut-être que ça
soit avec tous les autres réalisateurs
qui font partie de 15,5 des analystes 1
de toute l'équipe est également chez
unifrance qui est un gros un gros
plateau du cinéma donc on continue à
avancer de là dedans faire des démarches
auprès des villes pour essayer d'avoir
le soutien des villes pour les prochains
projets pour le prochain tournage voilà
on développe le programme on retrouve
les courts métrages dont vous parliez
les longs métrages également sur le lien
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
il ya en tout cas les bandes annonces
qui sont disponibles merci à gauthier
barras d'être venu parler sur ce plateau
de ce sujet directeur et fondateur de la
société de production ken production qui
est basé qu'elle cinq productions km5
faut rappeler le chiffre production qui
est basé à versailles pour terminer ce
journal on part à la direction dans la
direction de maurepas à la proche des
fêtes la municipalité bichonne ses
seniors des distributions de colis
gourmets ont eu lieu dans la ville plus
de 1000 habitants vont profiter de ces
douceurs de noël c'est les gars de 100
go pour égayer les fêtes de fin d'année
plus de 1200 colis cours mais ont été
distribués en porte-à-porte à maurepas
pour les seniors de plus de 62 ans ça
aurait été mieux qu'on aille danser
puisque cette année kobe 19 oblige pas
de repas de noël prévu comme tous les
ans gymnase ce titre on a souhaité avec
l'équipe municipale proposer davantage
de colis à tous les seniors qu'ils le
souhaitaient pour une personne ou de
personnes donc voilà on est une équipe
de plus de seize agents qui mobilisait
sur le terrain avec une douzaine d'élus
volontaires qui se prêtent au jeu pour
aller en porte à porte auprès des
seniors pour leur remettre le colis pour
les fêtes de fin d'année comme véronique
rocher adjointe à la culture qui a
distribué ce matin-là plus de quinze
colis
c'est pour deux c'est pour donc
absolument à wind annoncée pour demain
la voilà beaucoup c'est sympa vous
souhaitant de bonnes fêtes de pâques et
dans ce colis surprise plein de douceur
écoutez ya déjà une belle bouteille de
bordeaux au moelleux du blanc sublime de
canal de schiphol et puis des petites
confiture un petit bloc de foie gras
non c'est pas forcément mon job mais on
a fait appel aux bonnes volontés et je
suis vraiment ravi de pouvoir rencontrer
les maurepas gien à cette occasion là je
le fais pour la solidarité une
solidarité attendu par les personnes
âgées pour certains parce qu elle sans
voir leur famille et je vous parlais en
début d'édition de la présentation de
cet arbre le cèdre de montesson qui est
en course pour devenir l'arbre de
l'année vous retrouverez ce reportage
d'ores et déjà en ligne sur notre site
internet et v60 18 points comme et sur
l'application mobile voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité
demain vendredi vous retrouver et le
nord sinoquet pour une nouvelle édition
et dans un instant ne manquez pas un
nouveau numéro de si on rentrait
l'émission qui vous accompagnent pendant
cette période de confinement belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]